c'est le lieu c'est le moment idéal pour
se faire connaître la foire de tour la
troisième de France basse son plein
depuis ce week-end avant de parler de la
fréquentation avec l'organisateur focus
sur ses exposants qui misent sur la
formidable exposition que leur offre
cette fois pour se faire connaître des
toits terrasses sans chaleur au
repassage sans faire en passant par les
véhicules sans permis un reportage de
chapelet
la foire de Tours c'est évidemment des
vendeurs de meubles de nombreux artisans
et des spécialistes de la rénovation
mais c'est aussi quelques pionniers qui
tentent de mieux faire connaître leurs
produits c'est le cas de ce
Concessionnaire spécialisé dans les
véhicules sans permis il propose cette
gamme de voitures électriques en tandem
accessible dès 14 ans un moyen de
locomotion qui se démocratiserait chez
les jeunes depuis deux ans et qui
rassurerait les parents
beaucoup de jeunes s'intéressent à ce
type de véhicule en remplacement du deux
roues le ils sont beaucoup mieux
protégés dans une voiture que sur un
deux roues surtout lors surtout
actuellement dans les centres-villes il
y a de plus en plus de monde et ça leur
fait aussi quelque part une bonne
formation avant de passer le permis à 18
ans
dans un tout autre registre Sergio lui
présente sa table à repasser sans faire
c'est lui qui l'a conçu en 2006 un
produit qui fait son petit effet dans
les mains de son créateur
alors ça ne brûle pas ça ne feutre pas
ça ne lustre pas et vous gagnez 80% de
votre temps de repassage là c'est
terminé le linge il est mouillé mais
comme je vous ai dit si je mets la
petite flèche en bas 1 2 3 il est sec je
peux le ranger je le mets sur un cintre
et je le range voilà comment on repasse
avec ma planche
enfin cette peinture réfléchissante
pourrait bien être un produit d'avenir
avec le réchauffement climatique
appliqué en trois couches sur les toits
plats en goudron elle permet de réduire
la chaleur accumulée sur le bâtiment
d'un supermarché elle a fait descendre
la température de 64 à 27 degrés des
économies en perspective au niveau de la
climatisation un produit utilisé et
vanté par cette entrepreneur dater sur
Cher